I make about 55 to 62,000 a year I have
about $119,000 in student loan debt
$4,000 in credit cards and the rest is a
$335,000 car loan which I pay about $762
a month for whoa you're feeling that
yeah are you upside down on it yeah
definitely I owe $35,000 and the car is
worth $25,000 2021 Jeep Grand Cherokee
the net result is you've got to sell the
car and we have to figure out how
okay I imagine yeah yeah because the car
is killing you I mean it's safe to say
that if you didn't have this car you
probably wouldn't have even called us
the formula is we got to come up with 10
grand fast mhm and that means beans and
rice rice and beans all the OT you can
pick up or side hustles you can pick up
if you're not picking up OT and beans
and rice rice and beans no restaurants
no vacations no nothing that we get 10
grand to cover the whole that you're in
and then you sell the car and cover the
10 grand get you a $1,000 car